قلق متزايد بشان قدره الذكاء الاصطناعي
على احداث فوضى في اسواق العمل الا ان
هناك مهنه واحده فشل الذكاء الاصطناعي في
ان يجد له موضع قدم فيها او ان يكون بديلا
لها ما يجعل البشر الممتهنين لها اقل
توترا وقلقا على مستقبلهم الرياضيات
والعمليات الحسابيه فهو يجد صعوبه في
فهمها ويلجا الى البيانات للتستر على ذلك
ففي اختبار ان جامعه
25 سؤالا في المحاسبه نظم بين البشر وتشاد
جي بي دي قدمت الاسئله لاشكال مختلفه
وبمستويات متفاوته من الصعوبه لتكون
النتيجه بتفوق البشر بنحو 30% من
الاختبارات لكن تشات جي بي تي كان اكثر
مهاره في الاجابه على اسئله الاختيار من
متعدد واسئله صح خطا فان كنت محاسبا تشات
جي بي تي بعيد كل البعد عن المنافسه معك
[موسيقى]